gas has gone down by two cents merry
christmas i guess christmas came early
for you you grumbling ingrates
and uh by the way if you are having
trouble affording presents for your
family this christmas season or finding
presents even with the supply chain
crisis
why then you can just join in the novel
strategy
that appears to be very successful that
a lot of people in democrat cities
around the country are doing which is
putting on ski masks and busting into
stores and stealing everything and
the the great news about that strategy
is that if you do it you as long as
you're a member of a favorite group you
you almost certainly will not
be prosecuted for it people will just
look on as it happens and then let you
get away with all of the stuff jensaki
the white house press secretary was
asked about this strange phenomenon of
people busting into stores sometimes in
broad daylight and just stealing
everything out of the store and the cops
don't do anything and the da's don't do
anything even the security guards in the
stores aren't really allowed to do
anything
and
jensachi was asked what exactly is
causing this spate of crimes
when a huge group of criminals organizes
themselves and they want to go loot a
store a cvs a nordstrom a home depot
until the shelves are clean you think
that's because of the pandemic
i think a root cause in a lot of
communities is the pandemic yes this is
why the root cause of criminals
organizing into gangs and stealing
everything from
toiletries to gucci handbags and
everything in the middle and television
sets and everything sneakers is because
of the pandemic
the pandemic when the government just
paid people to sit at home and not do
any work
that's that's why
because i'm sure all of these criminals
were really productive members of
society before
2021 and just they're just down on their
luck and that's why they've got to make
out with a cart full of gucci handbags
after throwing a rock through a window
right
the the problem with jen saki's analysis
here other than the
manifest dishonesty and insincerity
is
is if she at all believes what she's
saying and i think the democrats to some
degree do
they are taking
the material view of man barack obama
used to do this they would say hey obama
how come things are so bad in syria and
iraq and they seem to be getting worse
actually on your raw on your watch and
barack obama would say well it's because
they don't have iphones it's because
they don't have enough jobs but once we
get them higher paying jobs and once we
get them iphones and once we get them
all the gizmos of american culture then
they'll stop waging jihad
and
it's a mistake that not only the modern
american left makes it's actually a
mistake that goes all the way back to
the foundations of liberalism
even classical liberalism or whatever
you want to call it this goes back
centuries
it's the mistaken view of man as
primarily an economic being
right the idea that stuff is the main
thing that motivates us
that's what
most of our modern society is based on
on the left and on the right
and on the left you see this with
communism once the people's material
needs are met then we'll all live in
utopia and with capitalism you see the
all people are really motivated by is
just making more money and buying more
gizmos and having more stuff but
i don't think that's true i don't think
that men are even are
entirely or even primarily motivated by
stuff
i think that we're motivated by dignity
by spirit by morality by affection for
our neighbors by a sense of loyalty and
duty to our community all the way up to
to god i think we're motivated by a lot
of different things i don't think that
we are primarily just stuff you know i
think we're stuff but we're also spirit
and i don't think that this is going to
solve
our problems we are more than just
consumers look at the west the decadent
west which has all of our material needs
met is burning
our our countries down we are we are
collapsing
it's not because we're not rich enough
the biggest problem afflicting the poor
in america is obesity we've got a lot of
stuff
but
because we're viewing ourselves
primarily as economic actors rather than
spiritual or metaphysical actors then
we're losing sense of what really
matters in
society
we're going kooky i mean our countries
are falling apart ring that bill
please
thank you i appreciate it that way
you'll get notifications if you don't
get notifications you want to also
subscribe to apple podcast spotify
stitch or google play wherever you get
your audio podcasts subscribe to the
michael knowles show leave a five-star
review if you don't mind
i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you